and then boom boom boom i'm the baddest
man on the planet
and he's ripped the table up it's dell
me eddie on adam smith from sky uh
gillian white mark tips that was the top
table and he's lifted
he hasn't thrown like something at him
he's picked the whole press conference
table up
and launched it across across me
for the people that aren't already
familiar with you and what you do can
you give us a
rundown of your history
well i'm first and foremost a boxing
promoter
um born into a crazy boxing family
people say how long you've been in
boxing and i say well i'm 43 years old
now
and i believe that my first babysitter
when i was two
um was it was was actually a world
champion at the time
so i had baby citizens boxers as a
teenager i worked in gyms in the summer
or when i bunked off school
my um my adopted godfather
was the late and great denny mancini who
ran lonsdale started lonsdale
and a little shot down before
blondesdale became big
and a little shot down um near carnaby
street big street in
soho and london and um used to skive off
school
just hang around a little shop you know
and watch the
watch the characters come in and out of
the shop you know it was everything from
from your east end gangsters to your
world champions to your
to your big men who boxed to the weekend
and were picking up some wraps so
you know it's it's you know boxing is
often
seen as a very glamorous sport a very
murky sport a very
colorful sport and you know this you
know
i've got to say in my
two and a half decades in the sport of
actually working in it
and actually my early days i've worked a
lot in football as well
um but it's just the characters that
make it
you know it's just the characters we are
on paper we're an unregulated sport you
know anyone can become a boxing promoter
tomorrow you've got you
beat in the in britain you've got to get
your british border boxing control
license
but the questions aren't the toughest to
answer um
actually i i don't even have a license
my brother's a licensed promoter so
um i've done the test so i don't know
how easy the questions are maybe i'll
fail but um
now we've certainly we know we've
promoted all over the world
from last year in japan um
actually i'm getting looking
it was the end of the year but just
before pandemic hits feels like last
year
2020 is a writer yeah you did 22
000 people in tokyo 18 million viewers
in front of the television
um we've done moscow and we've been to
you know all over the world we promote i
think we've promoted in more countries
than any other promoter
on the planet and you know it's it's
been a it's
it's it's a roller coaster ride and it's
it's great fun you know it's great fun
different travel promos we we've never
specialized in
or i've never specialized in one market
i've believed in
promoting all over the world and um and
it's
it's it's great great just when you
travel with boxing
you see the different cultures around it
you know in the different places you
visit
but you know the it's it's um
it's a world that has many stories and
many stories we can touch on when
when we have this hour what makes
a good boxing promoter if you're going
to design one in a lab what are those
sort of personality traits and the
characteristics that you give them
the first thing is you have to be
totally and utterly
mad that's the first part you have to be
prepared to devote your life and when i
say your life
i've i've had situations where i've
flown to wonderful parts of the planet
planned a
wonderful week in the sunshine a little
you know little one of those ocean
villas you know
set it all up nice week the second i've
stepped in
after a 16 16-hour flight i've had a
call off my lawyer
and said it's all going off in america
different time zones
so you can you never know when it's
going to hit you you're basically a
firefighter
so these great shows these big shows you
see
there's such a timeline and i can't
think of any big show that there's not
you know there's not murders around it
and my mommy murders in the obvious
sense i mean murders in terms of work
and the you know the arguments you have
with
you know sometimes it's fighters who've
signed for something up you know for a
certain amount of money then they argue
about the money afterwards or it's the
other promoter who's taking a liberty
or it's the trainer who wants to change
the date because you know trainers are
trainers they want to they're only
interested in the sporting side of it
but ultimately you're putting on
a massive event that is seen all over
the world
you know boxing is something that
transcends
any demographic you know there's kids
who love boxing there's
grandpas and great grandpas who love
boxing and great grandmothers who love
boxing actually
um so it's it's something
that you need to dedicate your life to
you can't say
i'm going to do it you know sort of as a
bit of a laugh you can be a manager
advisor and do that
yeah that's cool but if if you are a
promoter and you're promoting
shows especially at the highest level
you need to dedicate yourself 100 and
you have to accept that
yep family first of course but boxing is
a close second and
it always will be if not on par you know
and it's it's
it's a huge commitment and it's not
something that you can just think you
walk in and make a quick buck out of
because that ain't gonna happen there's
enough people who've fallen flat on
their faces
clever people very very clever people in
other businesses
who fought boxing it's all those
millions of dollars we hear about
but i tell you you got you want to take
them all as they come and
unfortunately you know sometimes you
need to get knocked down to the floor
and stand up and shake yourself off and
go another round even as a promoter you
know so
you know he always sounds so easy and so
brilliant on paper but
uh there's some very very tough times on
that road as well
other than fighting fires and trying to
sort of the people's [ __ ] out
like what's your job supposed to be what
are you actually supposed to do because
i hear about
this boxing's an iconic sport right and
everyone hears it even on the tv we get
to see behind the curtain a tiny bit as
the audience
that the fight's being made you know
that's like a sentence that you hear and
you're like
what do you mean like what's your job
what do you do
what do you do okay i'll start with i'll
start with the actual what does a
promoter do
it's no different to a concert promoter
the difference is we booked
two acts our two acts though are
gladiators
they are people who want to take each
other's heads off and we
you know so we sign these two up we
book a venue we sell the television
media rights these days the online
rights the ott
rights as you call them um there's a
sponsorship there's obviously the
tickets and you hope
that what you're paying the two
gladiators is
slightly less than what you're taking in
but it's not always the case
you know fighters will tell you now it's
always the case but it certainly isn't
always the case
so you've got to bust the gut over that
but then there's moving obstacles along
the way as well but you know
but on paper that's all we do we book we
book two
backs you know which is two gladiators
in our case book a venue and sell the
rights
and sell the tickets you know so it
sounds very simple on paper chris
um but at the end of the day you know
the fight
when you hear promoters say oh you know
this negotiation this
listen fights are very easy to make
if both want to tango so you've got two
guys who want to get in a real
or girls these days have been
increasingly popular
and great and becoming a great sport
female boxing but
it's if you've got two buyers who want
to
want to fight and then and they're
realistic and
and reasonable about it you do it very
quickly i remember doing
david hayne versus nikolai valuev i
remember if you
remember it was the the the beast from
the east the big russian giant the first
ever russian heavyweight world champion
david haye
and they've been talking for ages they
were supposed to fight the klitschko's
there were one klitschko brother they
would talk promote some moms and mums
i was in london i was um staying in the
dorchester i called up
that called up the uh i called up the uh
the manager at the time of david haye uh
adam booth
very bad reputation for being the dark
lord you know the
mega mega fussy guy and i'm thinking
right i might as well meet him on the
off chance they haven't done a deal with
the kids girls yet
we met for an espresso in the bar wasn't
even a gin and sonic
and at the end of the espresso we had a
deal we had a deal on
at least verbally we had a deal um
and we went off and and i had one of the
you know it was a massive event
uh it was one of the biggest
pay-per-views at the time
um you know david versus goliath and it
launched
the heavyweight career of david haye who
we went on to to co-promote for many
years afterwards so
it was um you know it was it was just
but it shows the reason i use that
example when people talk about how
difficult it is to make fights
of course we're all difficult characters
in books and we know that that's why
we're in boxing
but we all if you all want something
you make it happen so you know i think
some of it
is is ego you know it's some of its ego
but you've got someone step over your
own ego so luckily
i can i can see my shadow by my ego
but you know i'm not going to mention
names but there are some that they're
trickier than numbers but
at the end of the day it's not rocket
science you know we didn't go to
university to become a boxing promoter
and you don't need to either in fact i'd
like to see the statistic on how many
promoters actually went to university
that have a degree yeah that would be an
interesting one
so what did deals get held up by if you
can do one in the space of an espresso
what are the most common reasons that
you can't make a fight
okay on the on the the top top top level
normally those fighters are contracted
to different networks so
you know one might be with espn in the
states and the other one might be on
fox in the states the other one might be
on sky in the uk
or bt in the uk so then you've got to
work out
those are obviously very important
partners and that's the trickiest
part to those fighters and their
promoters so to suddenly say
sorry broadcast partner on this fight
you can't have it because we're going to
the competition it's of course a
difficult
discussion to have um but if you look at
probably the
the biggest financial the biggest
commercial fight in
in history was pacquiao mayweather
and there at the time that the thing
that got the fight done was
was it was hbo and showtime the two
biggest networks
they've been arguing for years massive
massive commercial enemies
and they said come on we both show it we
open it up and we
um we and it worked and guess what it
was
it was known as the the billion dollar
fight wasn't it i mean it was a terrible
fight but uh
yeah it was so but the build-up was good
wasn't it so
um they said you know it's always a
solution and
you know i think broadcasters would
rather there be a solution and maybe
share rights be non-exclusive but
actually see the fight happen
and um you know in the last few years
um i've been i've been running the world
boxing super series as as
as the chief boxing officer the main um
the main person on the sporting side of
things
and we put on the greatest fights in the
last few years
become known as the champions league of
boxing because we go out and take
the boxes out of there or borrow the
boxes as such out of their contracts and
and
and managed to create some so you know
the year before last but there was still
before the pandemic we had
out of the five fights of the year
globally we had the number one and the
number three
you know but we only promote was it ten
shows that yeah some proposals were
probably
50 shows you know probably a thousand
big shows that yeah
worldwide but uh that we managed to do
it with so few play if you bring the
best against the best it's always worth
doing in any sport
and that was our philosophy of that is
our philosophy at the world boxing super
series that
you know it depends a little bit on what
your ambition is
yeah and sometimes you know fights don't
get made
because it's easier to fight a lesser
opponent pay less for him
you know we'll work out the mathematics
yeah so you often see big champions
taking
you know taking the easy road sometimes
that's a shame for the sport but
you know people still watch it seems
crazy how many different parties you
have to juggle it seems like you're the
sort of keystone in the middle of a
bridge with about a million other stones
that are a part of it so you got the
broadcaster you've got the trainer
you've got the athlete you've got where
are they on their journey what's their
trajectory
who've they just fought what's their
record like what's the person that
they're about to fight and
and this is all multiplied by two
because you've got two different parties
coming in
it must be very difficult to kind of
blend all that together
yeah but chris is and the thing is it's
it's got a lot more complicated
because let's go back let's rewind you
know
people don't watch boxing too much think
about rocky the film rocky
you know rocky has a trainer you know
maybe he has a cat man in the corner
there's a broadcaster you know at the
time
let's say the 70s 80s in in in the us it
was i don't know
nbc abc you know it wasn't really much
of
uh much of a choice you know you got
signed up and the fight was done and
everyone thought each other it wasn't
complicated
now on both sides so if i go to the
boxer
the way that boxing's evolved as a sport
the training
is completely different so you don't
have
one trainer you know the top stars don't
just have a trainer
you know the training is now broken up
between
the boxing training which might even be
by the way
separate things there might be the
technical side of things the
power side of things strategy but you
also have
a dedicated strength and conditioning
coach that might also be broken up into
two things by the way that might be
strength and the conditioning side um
you then have the
the nutritionist side of things then you
have the the physiotherapist
by the way these are all voices at the
table
they might not be directly the table but
i remember
for example uh michael kessler very very
famous boxer from from
scandinavia one of the one of the best
super middleweights in recent history
he had a physio a great physio by the
way but he had just as much
impact on the boxer and his decisions as
his manager
so you know the the let's say the people
at the table
with a voice is much bigger you've got
um you've now got managers advisors
agents you know there's a new name every
day for something
they've entered the market somehow which
is normal in any sport in
football as well you know where there's
money and professional sport
you're always going to get that that
element and some are good
and some are not so good um then you
look at
then you look on the other side of what
we handle that so that's the money out
right that's the money i've got to get
the act as we said before
the gladiator but that's my deal with
him but then
i'm gonna go recoup my money who's that
that's that's of course the tickets but
that's
actually the easiest part of it and
but the the broadcasting side of things
hold on we used to just have you know in
the 80s richard
this your standard channels then we came
to the 90s satellite television the age
of digital
right so you had you know you started
getting uk you had sky sports suddenly
you know sky sports then went digital so
suddenly it wasn't scott sports one of
them
sports one two three four then they got
now we've had bt
enter on the on the paid television side
of things i'm using very much uk
examples but you can look also in the
states you know
espn expanding uh you could look in
in other in other markets everyone will
see it in their own countries but
on top of that now we've got these huge
streaming
services you know which are by the way
fantastic value and they're really
carving the market up now and making it
very tricky for the traditional
broadcasters
you look at the zone for example massive
massive impact
in the us in germany in spain and italy
and now they've launched globally so
you've actually got a platform
which is global and showing boxing all
over the world on one platform and it's
a fantastic
tool and for boxing fans it's it's the
greatest thing since it's slight spread
but yeah i mean yesterday even even
recently yesterday
also a new social media platform pops
up and and makes a huge impact in the
sport you know promoted recently
they had whatever one thinks of it but
the let's say the old man boxing with uh
with tyson versus jones which you know
you might like it or not but it did i
believe he did 1.6 million
buys yeah so you know that's that's
decent numbers for a couple of old
fellas
um snoop doggy dog said what are you
saying his commentary was like watching
my two uncles having a fight
so you know you know but but it but it
sells and you've got these youtubers now
and you know i've been quite vocal about
that i think it's okay i think it's good
to see youtubers
who want to take up a sport like boxing
i would
i let my kid box you know i would i
you know i think it's a great sport to
keep fit but it's
if you want to take it further it's a
great sport as well
to keep to have confidence and to be
able to defend yourself
but what they've done is some of them
have actually taken it quite
seriously i have a lot of respect for
that i don't like this
boxer versus youtuber because i find it
it's ridiculous but but the but the
youtuber versus the youtuber i don't
know if i've got respect for that if
they have proper camps
you know why not and it brings a a
target audience that is great for us is
of course the younger the younger fans
you know
i was going to say that must be you've
got jake paul against ben askren coming
up
ben's a wrestler although he's an
olympian he's a wrestler
you know you know what chris you know
more about me yes
so that's that's the next one you've got
logan paul and mayweather which has just
been pushed back
and then you have his younger brother
and you have a an olympic wrestler
now ben um ben's criticized sometimes
for his
striking and i think that's what makes
that fight slightly interesting but
you're totally correct
has there been in the sort of purist
boxing community
i imagine there must have been some
pushback it's seen as like this noble
art
the sweet science where's your stance on
this do you think that these youtube
boxing events should be allowed
i i think if they are youtubers against
youtubers and they have at a camp and
they've got themselves a license
i sorry there's no what what's the
difference between someone
off the street who wants to start to
become a boxer i mean as long as they
have a reasonable age they get licensed
absolutely go for it go for it i mean
it's great but then box people
on an obvious level so a youtuber
finding another youtuber
as long as they they've done the
training and everything and
i was i i was fortunate or unfortunate
enough to
have to wake up with my son and watch
the uh was it ksi against
um against paul fight i mean
listen as i said in my teens i hang
around gyms i've seen all sorts yeah
i i fought myself i was a terror i had
two left hands you know and
unfortunately i'm not a southpaw
so you know i've seen boxing at all
levels and
you know it was it was it was
entertaining i thought
i thought actually ksi was quite
athletic i think that below the pools
are clearly as well
but you know it's it's obviously levels
off floyd mayweather
you know i mean that's like me saying
yeah i had a bit played a bit of tennis
back in the day i'm gonna come
better i'm gonna do a three month camp
and i'm challenging you you know roger
federer and me
you know we'll do it down uh down down
the region's part we'll book a call
that's it you know i mean you know
seriously that that that part
it's entertainment though if they want
to do it then do it but but it's not
boxing you know
but listening makes probably makes a lot
of
number sense but what's the difference
between
that a youtuber fighting a youtuber and
a youtuber fighting a boxer then is your
concern for the safety of the youtuber
or is it something more kind of
uh sacred about the fact that mayweather
shouldn't be going down to the level of
someone that's just a youtuber
i think that i think that
first of all it's so unrealistic
that unless that boxer and this has been
the case mayweather's case
unless he toys with him and i don't know
froze throws his punches at 30 you know
um i think it's bloody dangerous
i think it's bloody dangerous i i think
that
it's not it's not tennis the example i
use with federal was a bit of a laugh
but it's it's a thing that if if you've
ever stood in a ring
and and you've i i've been i've been in
a ring with
as i've mentioned before there's a
terrible
gym fire that's how i would describe
myself i wouldn't call myself an amateur
as a terrible gym fighter who liked a
bit of a tear up as a kid
i remember being in a ring with um with
my old coach actually
he was he was a pro he was it was
nothing special he was a decent
but listen when i say nothing special
it's still a great credit to he was a he
was a british level
pro had to retire with some medical
reasons
early and became a trainer uh claire
great great trainer
and i remember him sparring with me
he wasn't even he was toying with me and
what do you understand it is the sweet
science if you can box properly
you won't come near me you won't be able
to even land
lever in my area yeah
and i remember standing oh in my right
hand
i was i was 19 20 years old
lots of testosterone in me and i was
i was giving it a real go and i was
following my right i just remember him
just moving
and dropping me with a with a body shot
and the body shot for people who don't
know
is aimed at the liver which has the
direct impact of cutting the oxygen to
the brain about two seconds later so you
stand and then
bomb you go to the floor and it was i
was like
whoa okay
that prospect of a pro contract he's
definitely gone
um probably didn't have helped a
terrible hangover from the night before
but liver certainly felt it and and it
was my memory you know
and that has always stayed with me so
when you see these journeymen in the
ring and you think oh my rubbish yeah
that journey even though if you stood
with him you wouldn't get near him right
so to say as and once again credit to
the youtubers i've been very harsh in
other interviews about but i do
give them credit for the training they
put in because i mean that
ksi wasn't was in the condition of his
life that paul like i said
it seems to be you know he's what he is
i think he's a bit of a knob when he
when he when he goes and talks every
disrespects fighters i think that's
disgusting and i think he deserves to be
put in his place
but the realism of him
and floyd mayweather who is once again
not my
ex british level pro trainer and you
know this is floyd mayweather
this is arguably definitely the greatest
defensive boxer
of all time so what
on earth are you doing in a ring with
him in your
in your what is it his second pro fight
and by the way
just to just just to put this on paper
he lost his first pro fight against ksi
so so he's got a record of norton one
and he's fighting the greatest defensive
boxer of all time
okay ricky hatton by the way ricky
hatton
a legend a great fighter
got knocked the [ __ ] out
by mayweather now you tell me
logan paul and ricky hutton have been
calling in the boxery
nothing apart from they both have two
legs that's
it there's no other similarity they
don't even have the same hands
yeah they don't even have the same hands
so logan paul
give it a go don't
mouth off about fighters when you are a
youtuber
let's get that straight you are a
youtuber
but you're very good at youtubing but
maybe be another youtuber first
and and then you know then you know then
call out
i don't know call out the local area
champion
you know maybe you know the greatest of
all time
and then talk crap about him as well so
it's but once again
i get it it's for business and it's fine
i just hope that floyd
has one hand tape behind his back at the
time
and floyd has the other hand tape behind
his head at the time
he'll still win then it might be a fair
fight he still wins because the other
way
if he wanted to wouldn't lay one glove
on him even without hands
so you know so how do i see it i think
it's i think it's great that these guys
are
they are making an effort to train it's
not like they go in there and just you
know
they do put their they do put the time
in the gym and that's all good
but they should be fighting at levels
which is entertaining for us you know
i'm not saying i was
super entertained now as a purist by
watching ksi logan paul
but i respected it i respected it and i
let my son watch it i let him
pay his five-year-old in pocket money
for it you know
yeah but if it brings that younger
audience in exactly
um i imagine that for you guys down the
line where are they going to be if they
watch
mayweather logan paul and they love it
and then they think well actually
this boxing stuff's all right and then
in they go to their local gym and then
maybe they
start paying for your pay-per-views
because they get into the more pure side
of stuff
i think what you've identified there is
it's kind of what everyone has in the
back of their mind
which is that the gulf in ability
between anyone that hasn't been a boxer
since they were a kid and dedicated
their entire life to it
and even the worst pro is probably
absolutely massive
and we don't we don't really realize
that because obviously
when you see mayweather pacquiao they
both make it look so effortless
but we might see probably for the first
time i think someone who's like a proper
noob you know like a normie stepping
into the ring with as you say someone
who's
essentially a ghost yeah and
but once again i think even
even conor mcgregor mayweather was it
was a fast
yeah i mean it was a fast that sold
a shitload of pay-per-views yeah
it sold and and it was a spec and i i
watched it
but i mean conor's a great fighter in
the in the terms
fighting you know he's a he's a mixed
martial
[Laughter]
sorry connor mitch mixed martial arts
expert and and he's and he's let's
let's face it he's he's been the face of
the ufc for the last
five years you know um
win or lose you know don't matter you
know it's conor mcgregor you know he's
the most recognizable face in the
history of the ufc
by a mile by a mile and
the only probably actually probably the
only fighter i would say that has
transgressed beyond the brand
of those three letters you know he's the
only one if he walked down oxford street
who everyone would pick out
george from pierre you could argue back
it back a few years but
when he walked down i was just straight
i don't think he would get stopped by a
mob
mcgregor certainly would alone by the
way he walks um
but now i'm digressing from the question
so
how do i see i once again i refer to
that fight because that is a fight
between a great fighter and a great
boxer
and it was in a way an interesting
spectacle did
did mayweather let him have a few rounds
to make it more interesting i'm pretty
sure he did you think i'm sorry
i'm pretty sure he did mayweather is
he's a genius
you know he is he is an absolute genius
in the ring
uh there's not been no fighter like him
ever
ever um not in terms of being exciting
going forward but he
i mean he developed the shoulder roll i
don't he developed the shoulder roll
which
if anyone doesn't know what a shoulder
roll is it's when you lift your shoulder
up
almost as a third hand to protect your
chin you know
he would ride punches with shoulders i
mean you know he did things in the
defensively so but this was against
opposition like oscar de la hoya like
ricky hatton i just mentioned like
canelo alvarez i mean he schooled canelo
alvarez
yeah and canelo alvarez wasn't a baby
then by the way he was an up and comer
but he wasn't a baby this is the
greatest fight on the planet at the
moment canelo alvarez and mayweather
schooled him but now mayweather knows
against logan paul you said that
mayweather is the best defensive fighter
of all time who's the best offensive
fighter
of all time in your opinion i think the
mainstream would always go with mike
tyson
you know i mean it's difficult to to not
i mean once i talked about the shoulder
roll
mike tyson developed the peekaboo style
you know which was
famously built by custom monster
probably the greatest trainer of all
time
um where he where he very famously put
across the ring a wire
between the two corners and would would
duck up and down between this
over this uh underneath this wire and
that was the style he developed you know
behind the two hands and
these ferocious hooks that came out of
it i mean mike tyson really threw a jab
um so you probably have to you'd have to
go with with tyson
um yeah i think mike tyson
is the equivalent in the offensive style
yeah talking about the ufc what's your
opinions on dana white
and what he's doing have you ever met
him i think i've i've
had nothing to do with ufc um in my life
i've i've looked at it from the outside
um
i think that it's uh it's a great
organization the way they've built the
sport i mean mustn't forget the story
line with the petite brothers and
dana and what a fantastic job i mean
i just look at it as a as let's say a
sports entrepreneur
and forget the boxing from our hat on
for a second and it's it's i mean it's
fantastic isn't it i mean they took a
sport
that was unregulated in debt and didn't
exist
and was partly illegal and turned it
into a 4.2
billion dollar brand you know i mean
what more is that
for me to say whether dana white's an
idiot or whether he's a great guy
i just i pulled my hat to him for that
so
um i could i couldn't comment on what i
think of dana white too i think
i think he's great value at a press
conference i like his style
um and i think uh when he when you see
when you see him with with the athletes
you can tell that he
is he lives it he breathes it i'm sure
he could have taken
an easy exit um after the sale he didn't
um which i think is has kept the brand
where it is
because it was very easy to sell for a
sport that
hasn't got that history to sunny off and
disappear yeah
and dana's definitely done a great job
post sale
pre-sell those fits eater brothers uh
though for me
modern-day geniuses in sport i mean what
they did with the brand
you have to look at it they had a there
that you can they could say oh well they
can do this they could have done that
well
if they picked a sport where they can't
launch you know
i mean the right the ratings are created
by them to play yourselves the
the the the whole environment is
self-controlled
and you know i don't think it's a
coincidence that there was no major
brand as a fighter that came out it was
always about the three letters
and boxing's very different to that you
know as promoters
you know world boxing super series or
team sourland eddie hearn with matroom
or
bob aaron with top rank you know let's
face
it who gives a [ __ ] about us
yeah so let's not take ourselves too
seriously with our brands
no one cares people want the gladiators
they want the fighters
you know um it's not about the promoter
the promoter yeah
we can sometimes we can be quite funny
we can make sure
you have arguments we can you know
it's a bit of pantomime stuff but at the
end of the day foxy's about two
gladiators
it's about the greatest fights the best
versus the best you know
and in ufc
it's always been about oh it's a ufc
fight
you know it's not the mainstream sitting
above you
i've been in a bar in the states sat at
the bar
ordered a beer ufc on the telly
and i have no idea who's fighting i
don't have a club i mean i don't know
much about ufc anyways but
but you sit there and you watch it and
it see anything
you can get into it you know it's for me
it's as a sport it's so technical
and i mean this is a compliment but it's
too technical if i don't underst you
know
like the holes i i find it very
difficult
my brother does jiu jitsu for example um
roger gracie um that's not my brother
but
he doesn't have a crazy school of jiu
jitsu
so but unless you do it you don't know
what
hold he's got in the floor and they're
just for me they're just rolling around
in a pair of spandex boxer shorts ain't
my cup of tea
um and and you know that that for me
is very complex to watch i like boxing
because i can be half asleep on the
couch with one eye open
watch the screen and i still understand
this man against man stand up
tear up you know do you think you go
down and there's a count
i think ufc is fascinating though
i think it's fascinating but i find it a
wonder and once again
credit to to the to the fatigue to
brothers and dana white for creating us
a spectacle out a sport that is so
technical that actually for the
mainstream it's impossible to follow
you know yeah but they you know when
they finish the fight and they jump on
each other and all that
you think that you get but to get to
that point
and you speak to the professionals about
the holds about what's going on on the
inside it's impossible to fight i mean
otherwise i've never done juice i've
never read i've done a lot of wrestling
on the pavement but i wouldn't i've
never been taught wrestling so i
wouldn't know the holds
you know you wouldn't know it's not a
street fight this is a
technical every move when they're on top
of each other it's like chess it's
fascinating
but it's chess don't sell because it's
too
it's too complicated you know so so
you know and people say listening might
say oh why can't a blob sport be so
complicated well i'll tell you something
it's the chess chests and fight sports
huge similarities huge similarities
massive and i've worked with a lot of
russian fighters
and easter block fighters and big chess
big chess players
i'm not saying a big chest you should
get into a ring now
but and vice versa probably not as well
but i remember speaking to a very old
russian trainer
about 10 years ago we were in a camp in
in in somewhere near siberia
and in the evening we're in the in the
in the sauna
and then we go out and watch him play
chess and he would explain to me
there's not much difference with a
fighting chess you've got your pawn
jab you know you've got when somebody
wins
when you when you're when you make your
move when you when you faint
when you so there's lots of different
things that that
and it's a i know this is going to sound
ridiculous for for some people listening
but
it's it's the most intellectual sport
boxing
you know i'm not saying all those fans
are boxing the most sexual people of all
time
but we appeal to all sorts you know uh
but
but uh but as a sport as a component
sport when it comes to
fitness strength mental ability
strategy there's no other sport that
covers that amount of components
there's no other sport where if you take
your eye
off what you're doing for one second
listen
i love i like i like around the golf i
like him love golf i'm terrible at it
and i hate it when i'm on the course but
i love it when i'm
on the course but when you hit that ball
you know if anyone plays golf they will
understand
that to take strike the ball is takes so
many different things that you gotta
figure out once
but if you screw it up okay worst case
you have to pull out the water and
drop for two and whatever it's okay but
you can save the round you can go on
birdie and eagle the next hole you take
your eye
off the price for one second in boxing
it's a very good chance you end up in
hospital so
that's the that's the issue you know
that's that's that's the thing and
imagine taking that focus required
and at the same time physically drained
mentally drained heat's getting to you
you're being punched the whole time
you're blocking
you know it's it's hell it and i that
i'm going to make a the only sport for
me
that comes close to it is downhill
skiing
the similarities of boxing and downhill
skiing is phenomenal
you have to fight the mountain you're
getting bumped the whole time
you're getting you've got a ice comes
your ski goals but you're going at 120
yeah
you're going down you're not going down
a a piste you're going down a i could
then be i'm pretty much down a cliff
which by the way in the morning before
the sun comes up
they've layered with water so you're
actually on ice
sheet ice i mean the it's for me it's a
phenomenal sport downhill skiing
phenomenal sport and that is the
that's the closest similarity in sports
i can see with boxing that
formula one you can argue you can argue
formula one you get
but my argument there would be
first of all the formula one these days
is a lot different to the formula one
seventies and the eighties in a good way
as well because
it was it was probably too dangerous at
the time um
but but at the same time it's if you've
got a huge team
guiding you through that when you're a
fighter or a double ski
you are out there alone you can have the
best promo in the world you have the
best coaches i'll be discussed before
you can have the best
media campaign but guess what when
everyone gets out that room
and everyone it's just you and the other
guy or the other girl
and that moment yeah is
is something that i think why boxing is
the only pay-per-view
sport or the only fight sport or any
sport actually there's no other sport
that works on pay-per-view they've tried
football they tried for they tried the
premier league actually during lockdown
it's the biggest moan of of the country
was that they're charging us for
individual matches pay-per-view matches
it fell flat on its face box is the only
sport that we buy as an individual event
people say oh well what can that be why
isn't why is that i think well it's
quite simple
you're paying for
and it sounds horrible but you're paying
for the suffering of this guy
or girl going through hell not only in
that fight but
you need to see what happens in a fight
camp they do
weeks and weeks if not months and months
of sparring
all different types they go on
they're crazy you know people talk about
iron man and full respect to it
get it forget to get it to get it going
to a boxing fight camp and see what a
fighter goes through
making weight yeah making weight
while trying to still gain muscle yeah
bodybuilders listening the hardest thing
in the world
lose weight gain muscle how's that work
you know pretty much impossible
but that's the you know again
bodybuilding you absolutely have certain
other uh
aids but um but you know
you know there's unfortunately been an
increased level of of doping in boxing
but that's the pressure of the sport and
you know i think it's a problem that
you're going to see that's because a
strict testing is stricter and strict
and it's also
the reason why you know certain people
are getting found out
and it will put people off we need to we
need to come up with lifetime bans
you know 100 percent uh we need to we
need to
in germany for example boxing is
actually
um it's a sport where that where
where which i i think if you enter this
there's certain substances which are you
know
increasing your ability to take a punch
yeah i mean that's pretty much like
suicide what if i
like what sort of stuff so so so you
could then stuff i remember um
actually mario's back he took it again
so i don't know what i don't know what
the name i'm not an expert on doping but
but he took it against klitschko and was
pounded into hospital
it basically keeps your senses going
well think about what it's for like it
chaos your body's protection right
i'm just about to say a ko it sounds
terrible now but okay i was actually
almost healthy i mean doctor's listening
was saying
stupid boxing probably here it's healthy
in the sense that it's the body
shutting down it's game over right i
know it's not healthy
so don't don't come at me and tell me
i'm talking [ __ ] i'm not talking [ __ ]
the way the body says it's game over
and imagine taking something that says
you could pound me
and i'm not gonna go okay oh i mean it's
it's
super dangerous for you for yourself um
but there's people doing that
and you know likewise
if i take a strength performance
enhancing uh
which is ultimately performance
enhancement whatever you want to call it
it's a drug
and you're taking these strength drugs
you're basically going in there with a
loaded gun aren't you
you know it's like me and you say come
on i said well let's have a water pistol
fight and you turn up with a magnum
right fully cotton loaded with redundant
bullets you know
so that's what it is so for me
when it comes to that type of that you
have to differentiate there's a big
difference between a doper who's using
it to cut weight yeah not not
that's of course it should be bad
but the band must be different for
someone who is using it
for actually going into a ring
it's the same we're putting a horseshoe
in my glove
where's the difference if i'm taking
something and
this is proven scientific reports um
which would show the strength difference
and boxing isn't a sport by the way of
muscle so
if you see a guy with muscles don't
necessarily worry
his power i can show you boxes that look
like
rakes yeah which are definitely not
beach bodies
who would smash holes in the guy with
muscles it's
totally relevant but there are strength
enhancing drugs actually
there was a boxer um uh urkan tepper
named him shame him
um a turkish german fighter
he fought against david price on fire
and he hit him knocked him out in two
rounds
and i was thinking after flight mate
this guy he looked like
he looked like someone who who who'd
been who spent his life working in a
kebab shop i mean
his body looked like it was it was
terrible but you see heavy weights right
there and they're fit as a fiddle
you know but this guy he there was
something about him
i remember sitting there waiting in the
dope in control with david and him and
they was
devastated i'm just looking at this guy
he's too cocky for his own good and
and they found a steroid factory in his
in his flat
so he got intensely positive poor
strength
and that for me is a case of what's the
difference between that
and taking off horseshoe and putting in
our old school like you see in the films
you know
the cartoons are putting all show man
and mate
if you punch someone on the street what
can you get done for abh you get three
years
yeah you go someone on the street with a
with a knuckle duster you punch them
you're gonna go down for up to seven
years what's the difference
in boxing should be exactly the same
thing if it's if it's a strength
enhancing drug
put them away put them away simple as
that
you know but you need to cut we're in a
day and age
of where you need to quantify the
punishments
according to the drug and it's not about
well doping this um listen doping is
is not welcome at all in boxing and in
fact we've invested as a company we've
invested
hundreds and hundreds of thousands per
year
in in doing these tests we were the
first promoters in the 90s who started
bada testing
you know we put it in training tests we
were first promotes on planet earth to
do it
and i remember the time we had
i said we
we were made to do it by our broadcast
partner it was when all the cycling
kicked off all the
uh the epo stuff and
you know we did it it cost us an arm and
a leg but you know what we had a clean
we had a clean conscience and actually
to be fair in 10 years i think we caught
two people
one of them with [ __ ] weed i'm like
mate banning for stupidity i mean that's
stupid i mean listen
i get there's some drugs you'd want to
take before a fight
weed is not one of them yeah that that's
that's for sure man that's for sure
so i mean what i mean who take you
smokes and joining goes into the ring i
mean
you know so you do get some lunatics but
um but on the whole
has boxing or adobe problem no no are
they dopers in boxing
absolutely not any professional support
will they get caught eventually they
will yeah
and they need to get the front book
pronoun
going back to your side of the gig
is there a particular event that you've
been most nervous before
a particular performance that you've had
ready to go
i mean i've had some crazy ones over the
years i mean
i've had some let me think of some
nervous nervous ones i mean
i had i remember one i wasn't
nervous before the event was only during
the event we did the first heavyweight
championship of the world in in
switzerland
um so it was the first ever
world heavyweight championship to take
place in in switzerland not places
associated with boxing although muhammad
ali didn't actually box in zurich
so we did it together it was with uh my
partner at the time don king who
most people know the guy with a the
tallest hair on the planet
and what a character i can give you a
whole
list of stories about don king but this
one this one's one that stood out
because
we we've done this eventually was the
first ever event they didn't know much
about boxing
and you know switzerland's not a cheap
place so
the tickets were very expensive and they
were about three four thousand
for the vip tickets um which did get you
a glass of glass champagne and a bit of
photograph
but you know it's still about the show
so we had a big pop act on i think it
was roland keating and
singing at the fight with the lasers
going off anyways
so the fight starts and it was uh it was
valuable but we talked about earlier
the bit this huge was it
seven foot three heavyweight champion
biggest heavyweight champion of all time
and he's fighting an american called
drameen mclean so
the swiss are sitting there they're
watching you know they've paid big money
to watch this fight
second round mclean's thrown a punch
totally missed
totally missed slipped on the canvas on
our sponsor logo so i'm thinking oh my
god right
and i've seen him go and i i do a fair
bit of training myself so i
i recognize straight away what he's done
he's done his meniscus he was it was
game over it was no way he was getting
back up there was no fight on
it was it was over in you know
he was he was gone you know he couldn't
continue
so i'm standing thinking oh my god no
whoa
so don has jumped up and anyone who
hasn't seen donny always carries his
flags and donald sweeping the flags and
shouting and screaming and saying
amazing amazing and i'm thinking
oh my god how are we going to explain
this like this can happen in boxing we
can have it in any sport i guess but
you know federer can trip and beat swiss
isn't he so he can you know
break his ankle in the wimbledon final
god forbid but
it can all happen but i'm standing in
the press of rust over
and luckily donna's stood up
and taken the lead because i didn't know
what to say
and he's like did you see that guys did
you see that and i'm thinking
did you see what the guy slipped on the
canvas
he punched him it was a delayed effect i
mean he hadn't eaten about 20 seconds
before
before the incident it was a delayed
effect
it was the punch the sucker punch from
russia with love
and he's waving the flags and they're
going
but the thing was he couldn't sell ice
to the eskimos
all day long they lacked it up
the people were so he turned this this
thing into this fabled
punch from russia with love and i'm
thinking now this isn't this is just too
much and
and you know and and i've got so many
stories
we've done over the years um you know
but
that was let's say one of the one of the
most nervous moments that
i think that that jumps out of me but
there's plenty plenty plenty i mean i
also i remember the the first time
you know i was in my late 20s i flew to
russia
and you know my first time in russia and
i was
trying to sign the olympic champion at
the time heavyweight champion alexander
povetkin
and in the process of doing it i had to
you know meet the guys and you know you
know let's put this way
um they were they were
they weren't exactly businessmen let's
let's put it that way and i was taken
out to this remote village about an hour
outside moscow
my phone suddenly went like no more
search signal like suddenly so i
realized they're using scramblers so you
couldn't even get a
get service in the area it was all you
know it's proper movie stuff
and i'm thinking where am i i ended up
staying there for about a week
played with vodka at the greatest time
and came home with a contract
but it was it was stepping into the
unknown you know i mean
it was russia yeah i had a translator
who flew over with me
um but it was it was one of those one of
those many situations that boxing throws
you into when you know in
your late 20s it was the first time i've
been in russia it was certainly
it wasn't like it was a trip around the
red square and uh
and a bit of mulled wine it was uh it
was straight out to somewhere
remote which no one knew and i
disappeared for three days
talking about boxes and the way that you
deal with them you are present at most
of the press conferences
and there's always a couple of
highlights i know that you've worked
with some names in the past that have
been pretty fiery
have you had some that have been
superbly hard to control
or sort of any uh press conferences that
have that have really gone too bad for
you
loads i mean you know that's the famous
one you know
um can i swear on here i swear away i
probably know so yeah
i mean it's the famous one with chris
eubank junior and
uh the turkish promoter ahmed owner
where he turned around and had a fight
with the security guard and pulled his
you know went over almost head-butted
each other then he went back took his
blazer off and
rolled up his sleeves and then told him
that he was going to [ __ ] his wife
in his head you know and and if anyone
hasn't seen us
sincerely rolling cameras live on german
television
and if you haven't seen it it is worth a
watch on youtube somewhere you'll find
it
but i mean the the the character without
any question that i have promoted over
the years
he was second it's him and then there's
no one else you know
you must think you must guess it chris
there's the one and only i mean
derrick trezora i mean the stuff that i
have went through with del boy and and
i love them you know he's
he was i used to call him my unfortuba
um
you know absolutely crackers uh one of
by the way outside the ring one of the
nicest family guys you'll ever meet
a real gen um live in this we live in a
similar area in london and we often bump
into each other the butchers
but i mean you know what has he done to
me at press conferences i don't know i
remember once did he and why
you know it was all this heated argument
between him and didn't white big if
you're not from the uk was a big british
heavyweight fight
and i remember we had the press
conference in manchester
and um dell boys come up and i've said
they'll come on let's have a quick
chat before the press conference we knew
before it was going to kick off it was
live on tv it was live on sky news and
so i said dale listen you know what
today let's try it different
this you take let's take the moral high
ground here
let's take the no let gideon's going to
come for you
let him look like the the thug the you
know the
the bad guy take the mic let's try and
win over some fans in it's come on we
can use it
trust me it's like a counter attack yeah
yep i think that's a great idea sat down
anyways
press conference started and you know
gideon
sounds off boom boom boom boom boom you
know
you're this you're that i'm gonna do
this you know i'm gonna do you on the
street if i see you and he keep was
going off
derek's just sitting there derek always
sits at a press conference with his
sunglasses on
and he shows no reaction but so i'm sat
next to dell
and all of a sudden i felt like the
table
sort of and he's getting it he's had a
few wrong questions he's asking them
quite sensibly i thought
he's listening to me well that's i'm
impressed
right and i've just felt the table start
to shake
and it's his legs have started trembling
and then i'm looking at him thinking i'm
looking behind those glasses his eyes
are still closed though it's like he's
sleeping and he's still
like dreaming and his legs are going and
then
boom boom boom i'm the baddest man on
the planet and he's
ripped the table up it's me no still
me eddie on adam smith from skype uh
julian white mark tibbs that was the top
table and
he's lifting he hasn't thrown like
something at him
he's picked the whole press conference
table up
and launched it across across me
he gave me i swear to god he i had
a bit of stubble i think it gave me a
nice two millimeter shave
it was fantastic the pictures afterwards
you can see if
you see he was across all the back pages
of the paper to the next edit
me sort of trying to lift the toed up
protect myself from the table
and he sort of half landed on eddie and
he sit next to me
but the funniest thing was i i looked
back at
the tape and i was so shocked i didn't
actually do anything i just stood there
like frozen like what the [ __ ] has just
gone on there
but i was still you know i don't know
one more one more for the for the road
or dell
way in germany this actually this one
was probably even better but not so
famous in the uk but this one so we had
a wave again he was fighting kubrick
i've booked the four seasons right the
four seasons in hamburg
is the poshest hotel i've ever been
let's say posh in terms of old school
posh you know they've still got the old
t-boys with the tea sets they're very
relevant for the story in a minute
so we've had the thing the way in
and actually
dell was gonna and
there is sometimes a bit of banter and
you know there is a
show element to it but dell was gonna
basically i knew
that he had bought a big black dildo
all right and he was gonna hit the
kubrick he just wanted to
i don't know he was gonna hit him or
give it to him because they were talking
about
penis sizes earlier in the week at the
press conferences and i think he was
going to give it to him or give him a
cheeky slap with it
he had it in his hand and they've gone
to face to face
and i've seen it in his hand and i'm
thinking oh my god what's he going to do
with it
before he can do anything with it so
they're face to face at the weigh in
both
tops off derrick's got his trademark uh
union jack
bandana on around his mouth looks scary
as hell but kubat pull up don't look too
unscary either the big bulgarian
face off right you've got 240 kilos of
muscle up there
right no one is getting between these
two guys and in one of poulem's corner
before derrick can hit him with it would
have been
with a black dildo
so he's jumped over the top and hit down
with an avian ball
i look chilly like plastic over here so
i'm standing there i'm thinking
oh my god and you can't even say
security security in that moment there's
nothing you can do to stop dell
dell is like a buffalo if he wants to
run through
he will go through and he'll go through
walls right so you know
and i just remember there was a room
with cat was a ballroom
and he's forgotten about pulav
the dildos dropped the floor but i've
kicked it away quickly because i thought
that's the only thing i can do
to be fair my brother my brother
actually
tried to half stop him i mean i've gotta
give my brother deserves a medal of
honor for trying
and derek has chased off this guy he's
ran
through the kitchen some photographers
running after
you know where they were with their with
with the cameras
and derrick has has cornered the guy in
the kitchen
and is in that moment a guy with a t-set
like i said old-school tea set you know
one of those
those sort of uh the the doorbell what
is it
the doorman hats and he's just looked at
derrick this guy's storming through the
kitchen
after this bulgarian and derek with a
bandana on and has just dropped the tea
set
and derek just couldn't get out of the
bulgarian and somehow managed to leg it
and he got away
but man i got a bill from the four
seasons in hamburg
i i think it was at least 25 grand worth
of damage in there yeah it was insane
the whole kitchen went flying and it was
brilliant brilliant brilliant so no that
was uh that was derek chizora
yeah but i've got long i've got more of
dell but we've been here all night
mate my final question
that i've had through my head throughout
this entire thing and i i heard
um eddie hearn on the high performance
podcast with jay humphrey which is a
really really good one if anyone wants
to check out about eddie
how do you deal with the pressure
that you have on you because this
pressure is incredibly intense you are
like the crux of everything that's going
on
the book stops with you how do you deal
with all of this pressure
um no i mean listen the pressure
ultimately is
you have a responsibility on the night
you know there's so many pressure points
coming up to it when
you know you've got you've announced a
fight and
and someone tries to renegotiate
afterwards had that before i've had so
many
i'm not going to use the words blackmail
but you know there's there's certain
people you know they they have a
contract you announce the fight
and then they see how big it is and then
they
come back and say oh well you know
actually
i want a bit more money you say no you
can't be well but
look how huge he is now i said but that
was my pun
you know that's the thing so there's
lots of different ways you can work with
fighters you work on percentages and and
take the risk and pay the flat fee so
you get those situations where you know
you either
call it all off and say right i'm going
to sue you because we have a contract
and you're not following that contract
you call the bluff you don't call the
bluff you give in you know
if you give him once he will give him
for always so you don't really
you don't give it you can't give in
because it's the beginning of the end
so there's those sort of situations but
i think if you look at the pressure i
think
i get nervous around fights um
that we mustn't forget what we do we are
the orchestrators of controlled violence
and that sounds really cool
that sounds like responsibility pure
and like wow you know man what you do
yeah i put on fights that's a cool one
in it
you know that's a great one news down
the club that's a great one you know
as a as a as a as a pickup line
well i don't know about that probably
run the other way
but you know what joking aside i have
been
with fighters and their families
in a hospital room after fights
so the ultimate pressure for me
is actually on the night when
i get that call that everything from the
doctor that
the whole thing has gone successfully
and when i say successfully it's not the
pay-per-views it's not
that's the stuff for the monday but the
call
on the night that we have had a clean
bill of health
you know and that and i've had
horror stories you know and boxing
thankfully
today in 20 2021
is one of the safest sports on the
planet
but we mustn't forget what the purpose
of boxing is
uh it's of course you know you can zoom
out the first rule of boxing is defense
but let's face it you know um
well as mike tyson said everyone's got a
plan to get punched in the face
that's boxing you know i spoke to one
one of my fighters um philip bergovich
spoke to him in um in lockdown he said
just dying and punch someone in the face
kelly you have to get me out that's what
they do and
yeah but chris we can laugh about it and
i laugh about it and
that's what we want to see you know
there's two things
since the start of mankind since we have
heartbeats
there's two things that will happen on
the street right now
and we will both run to the windows and
pick up our iphones and start filming
can you name them i'll let you okay
i'll tell you what the first one is sex
you've got a couple outside [ __ ]
you're gonna go to that window and
you're gonna start filming
yes or no yes yeah how many videos have
you seen viral
i look i caught them at the you know
hotel room and they were leaving against
the window
you've seen it all half a fake half a
real
okay sex will always sell we'll always
sell
the other violence you see two guys
fighting in the street what's the first
thing oh where's the phone
exactly those two instincts
yeah are something that are in
our nature we can't change that
what i do is not the sex part is well
not at least for business um is
i my goal
is to bottle that
put it on the big stage and get as many
eyeballs as i
can on that to give these gladiators
the true platform so i go back at the
end now
to the beginning question what do i do
chris
that is what i do
mate i love it i've really enjoyed
appearing behind
myself actually very arty
[Music]
but it's true that's that's what we do
and we mustn't forget
what fighters go through deserves that
at every level if it's a club fighter
and he's got his big night
you know i've bought tickets for loads
of white collar events to support my
mates my brother had a few
you know that's their moment that
walkout music
you know that's that moment and we
should that is something that should be
celebrated and
and and you know it's it's not i don't
put down any other sports yeah but it's
something very
very special and unique to give that for
other people's viewing pleasure
the thing that really interested me was
you talking about how unique boxing is
with its pay-per-view
the fact that you can't get people to
pay that money for
football when you've got 11 guys on the
pitch who get
paid in a week what most people get paid
in 10 years and
all this sort of stuff you are right
there's something ritualistic and sacred
and symbolic
about about boxing and um yeah it's
it's fascinating it's fascinating to see
behind the curtain as a final thing i
know that you've recently signed
mr eubank jr what what do you think and
obviously you've got your
uh world boxing series and all this
other stuff coming up
what should we be looking out for over
the next sort of 12 to 18 months in
terms of
people to keep our eyes on and events to
look out for
but i think in in terms of uh be stoked
because
chris eubank jr i mean you know he's
been away for a while
um from the uk especially he had the
big fight against james the girl but
that is
that's two years ago it was a great
victory and he went off to the states
um had some success there and then
unfortunately the pandemic hit
and hit him hard you know he's one of
the one of the greatest trainers on the
planet
um in his dedication i mean you know
he's got
fantastic social media following and you
know
hangs out on weekends with dan bilzerian
you know
he's he's a real lifestyle guy if you
looked at him on instagram
you'd think when did where the hell does
this guy ever train you know it's you
know him playing poker it's him in this
you know
the guy doesn't drink a drop he doesn't
he's
lives an absolute pure life
um he's in the gym every day the way he
cuts his instagram is fantastic i mean
she must have a film editor doing it
because i mean
stuff that you watch on netflix but
you will see him back this year you're
going to see him back probably
um late april in a tune-up
and you'll see him in a very big fight
this summer
um you know we've mentioned certain
names there kell brook
for example we've talked about gunner
golovkin
morata there's some very big fights in
the weight class for him
and you know he will fight
three times this year so that's that's
from a uk perspective i think
uh something very much to look forward
to in the world boxing super series
we're gonna be back with a new season
soon
it's obviously we had a a tough time in
the pandemic we got we got
finished we actually managed to finish
the second season during the pandemic
which is fantastic
and you know we're we're working on now
to see
you know there's great signs for all
sport isn't it you know this vaccine
you know what everyone thinks about it
you know let's let's let's be
fair there is light at the end of the
tunnel and
you know i think for boxing and all
sports and
all events you know i think it's going
to be such a bounce back
so anyone listening who's in in in areas
hit the ground i'd tell you i had the
worst year last year just just mentally
you know not you're not getting out not
traveling not going to events that's
what i've lived on over the last
25 30 years you know my whole life
really and
you know i think that those industries
whether it's
music events night clubs
living life tourism you know
getting out there traveling again man
this is
you know people who tell me oh well the
world's changed and we're all gonna be
sitting at home for the rest of our
lives i
can't do one mate you know i say
this will bounce back we now will do
this
and realize how privileged are we are to
be alive
and enjoy and everything we do we will
we will not maybe in in
a year of so many miserable disgusting
news of
watching death mates like they were the
football scores
um maybe what has come out of this
is that we will all take life a little
bit more
i'm not saying more likely but you go
and enjoy you know enjoy what you do
you know and if you don't enjoy what
you're doing then change
change something i know i know it's it's
easy to say
when when when i've been lucky enough to
to work into myself into this position
but
but at the same time man whatever is it
you do just live go and live you know
and enjoy you know if you when i when i
drink
drink a bottle of water now i and it's
nice and cold enjoy the tea
it's the whole enjoyment of life and
that's gonna come back
big time big time people so
chin up we'll get through it you know
and that's it's not coming from someone
who's just made
billions off the uh of the pandemic you
know there's someone who's had a
[ __ ] shittiest year ever
but hey i look on the bright side i
spent more time
with with my kids than ever before
um
[ __ ] homeschooling is one that i
definitely want to [ __ ] forget
um thank god for google um you know
but so but that's you know i'm i've
always been a
um glut the glass is half half full sort
of fella
but you know head up
pull up let's roll up our sleeves and
crack on
i'm looking forward to this year mate i
really hope that everything comes back
in line for you uh if anyone wants to
sort of keep in
keeping loop with what it is that you
guys are doing
where it's best for them to uh to sort
of
be updated with team silent i mean
we keep saying follow us at the on salon
brothers saul and bros
s-a-u-e-r-l-a-n-d bros um
and yeah catch us catch us on social
media
on all forms i like to rant on twitter
my brother
prefers his instagram um but yeah
no we're out there and we're looking
forward to uh to a big 2021
man thank you so much for coming on
thank you very much
you